[Music]
some of the world's most recognizable
symbols exist to sell products others to
steer traffic or advance political
causes
but there's one whose main purpose is to
help people you may know it as the
wheelchair symbol or a sign for people
with disabilities but its formal title
as maintained by the ISO is the
International symbol of access but
despite its familiarity many people are
unclear as to what the symbol actually
means which has a lot to do with the
symbol itself and the way it came about
in 1968 the International Commission on
technology and accessibility held a
design contest they were looking for a
symbol that would be readily
identifiable from a reasonable distance
self-descriptive simple practical and
couldn't be confused with existing
signage the winning design which didn't
have a head was created by a Danish
designer named Suzanne Coe fed the
addition of a head a year later gave it
a more human form and within 10 years it
was endorsed by both the United Nations
and the ISO with minimal cost and
minimal fuss a global icon was born
there have been a few tweaks over the
decades the graphic artists guild added
more rounded human-like features and in
2012 the accessible icon project
produced a more dynamic version but what
does it really represent what's its
purpose put simply it's assigned to
identify where there are accessible
facilities the strength of such an
internationally recognized image is that
wherever you travel you don't need to
speak the language or have in-depth
cultural knowledge if you require an
accessible toilet the sign shows the way
but the confusion comes from the term
accessibility and what that actually
means many people assume that because
the symbol depicts a wheelchair that
accessible facilities are meant only for
people who use wheelchairs or those at
the very least who have a visible
physical condition but accessibility is
a broad concept that applies to many
many
different conditions that includes
people with autism visual impairments
and autoimmune diseases like lupus which
can cause pain and fatigue along with
many other conditions in fact the World
Health Organization estimates that there
are approximately 1 billion people who
experience some form of disability which
means that this group is very likely to
include yourself or a family member a
classmate a friend or a work colleague
and people who use wheelchairs only make
up about 65 million or 15% of the total
the vast majority have non visible
disabilities accessible parking spaces
facilities and entrances are designed
with that entire group in mind so it's
easy to see why in recent years people
have begun to raise questions about
whether the symbol is really appropriate
for what it's meant to do and it's not
just about accuracy it's common for
people to become indignant sometimes
abusive when they see people without
visible disabilities using accessible
facilities the symbol is unfortunately
creating widespread issues for the very
people and families it's meant to help
the recent redesigns have attempted with
some success to acknowledge concerns
over the current symbol but some think
that a complete redesign is in order
it's a difficult task though how do you
replace a symbol that's familiar the
world over and what do you replace it
with
you
[Music]